The 2020 U.S. elections were some of the most divisive and vitriolic in modern history, leaving many Americans exhausted and dispirited. And if you're thinking our country seems more polarized than ever, you're not alone. In a recent paper published in the journal Science, a group of psychologists, political scientists, and other social scientists found that the level of contempt between Americans who identify as Republicans and those who identify as Democrats has been increasing over the past 30 years. These days, many Americans don't just disagree with their political opponents.
2020年美国大选是现代史上最具分裂性和尖刻性的选举之一，让许多美国人感到精疲力竭、心灰意冷。如果你觉得我们的国家似乎比以往任何时候都更加两极分化，那么你并不孤单。在最近发表于《科学》杂志的一篇论文中，一组心理学家、政治学家和其他社会科学家发现，在过去30年里，自认为是共和党人和自认为是民主党人的美国人之间的蔑视程度一直在增加。如今，许多美国人不仅仅是与他们的政治对手意见不合。
They see them as immoral and even abhorrent. Some have termed the climate in our nation as a civil cold war. What are the causes of this deepening rift? Is there any way to reverse it? And is it dangerous to the future of our democracy? These are some of the questions that we'll answer today on Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and
他们视对方为不道德，甚至是令人厌恶的。有些人将我们国家的这种氛围称为一场“冷内战”。这种日益加深的裂痕的原因是什么？有什么方法可以扭转它吗？这对我们民主的未来是否危险？这些就是我们今天将在《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）中回答的一些问题，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与
everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. If you enjoy speaking of psychology, the conversation does not have to stop when the podcast is over. Get unlimited access to hundreds of videos about the latest in psychology for just one low price by registering for access to APA's 2020 virtual convention. Start with some of our selected videos featuring psychology's biggest names discussing topics such as COVID-19, racism, and stigma. or let your curiosity take over and use our on-demand library to explore any topic. Go to convention.apa.org slash podcast.
日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。如果你喜欢《心理学谈话》，那么播客结束时对话不必停止。注册参加美国心理学会（APA）2020年虚拟大会，只需支付一笔低廉的费用，即可无限次观看数百个关于心理学最新动态的视频。从我们精选的视频开始，这些视频汇集了心理学界的大咖，讨论诸如新冠疫情、种族主义和污名化等话题。或者让你的好奇心驱使，使用我们的点播库探索任何主题。请访问 convention.apa.org/podcast。
That's convention.apa.org slash podcast. My guest today is Dr. Eli Finkel, a professor of social psychology at Northwestern University in Chicago, who co-led the group of 15 researchers who wrote the recent paper in science. He studies romantic relationships, American politics, and the intersection of those two topics, and he's here today to talk about his research. Welcome to Speak on Psychology, Dr. Finkel. I'm delighted to be here. The title of the paper that I mentioned is political sectarianism in America,
网址是 convention.apa.org/podcast。我今天的嘉宾是芝加哥西北大学社会心理学教授伊莱·芬克尔（Eli Finkel）博士，他共同领导了撰写这篇《科学》杂志论文的15人研究小组。他研究浪漫关系、美国政治以及这两个主题的交叉点，他今天来到这里是为了谈论他的研究。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，芬克尔博士。我很高兴来到这里。我提到的那篇论文的标题是《美国的政治宗派主义》，
and in it, you and your colleagues write about how political sectarianism today is like religious sectarianism in the past. Why did you choose the term sectarianism to describe what you're seeing in American politics today? I'm glad you asked that question. There were basically two reasons. The first is to distinguish. between two different types of polarization. One is a polarization based on ideas, that is, Democrats and Republicans differing in their political ideals or their policy preferences. And the
在文中，你和你的同事写道，今天的政治宗派主义就像过去的宗教宗派主义。为什么你选择“宗派主义”这个词来描述你在当今美国政治中看到的情况？我很高兴你问这个问题。基本上有两个原因。第一个是为了区分两种不同类型的两极分化。一种是基于思想的两极分化，也就是说，民主党人和共和党人在政治理想或政策偏好上存在分歧。而
second is a more interpersonal, social psychological type of polarization, which is increasing distance and animus toward people on the other side. So that was one of the reasons why we wanted to make the distinction is we're talking about the second type of polarization, the social psychological thing rather than these political ideals. But sometimes people talk about that second type of polarization using the word tribalism. And we had planned to use that term for a while and we shifted away from it at the end here again for two reasons. One is that it's become increasingly clear that using the word tribalism in a generally derogatory way is at best a sensitive issue vis-a-vis indigenous Americans. More and more people have been voicing that concern. And the second thing is that the
第二种是一种更具人际关系和社会心理学意义的两极分化，即对另一方的人产生日益增加的距离感和敌意。所以这就是我们想要做出区分的原因之一，因为我们讨论的是第二种两极分化，即社会心理学层面的东西，而不是这些政治理想。但有时人们用“部落主义”这个词来谈论第二种两极分化。我们曾计划使用这个词一段时间，但最后我们还是放弃了，同样有两个原因。一是越来越明显的是，以一种普遍贬义的方式使用“部落主义”这个词，对于美洲原住民来说，充其量是一个敏感问题。越来越多的人表达了这种担忧。第二个原因是，
we're tribalism, at least to me, pulls for metaphors around kinship, around family. And really what we're seeing is something closer to a holy war between the left and the right these days. So in that sense, we wanted something that had more religious connotations. So why has sectarianism in the U.S. increased in recent years? What's behind the rift? So we talk about a few different reasons in the paper. One of them is that political orientation has increasingly come to function. as a mega identity. It used to be that you had plenty of liberals in the conservative party and plenty
“部落主义”这个词，至少对我来说，会让人联想到亲属关系、家庭之类的隐喻。而实际上我们所看到的是，如今左派和右派之间更接近于一场“圣战”。因此，从这个意义上说，我们想要一个具有更多宗教内涵的词。那么，为什么近年来美国的宗派主义有所增加？裂痕背后的原因是什么？我们在论文中讨论了几个不同的原因。其中之一是政治取向已日益演变成一种“超级身份”。过去，保守党里有很多自由派，民主党里也有很多
of conservatives in the Democratic Party. It used to be that people's social demographic categories were not determinative of which party they were in. But increasingly these days, if I tell you that somebody's a white evangelical, you have a pretty strong clue about what party that person is in. And that goes for race and gender and all sorts of other issues like that or other demographic and social categories. So part of the issue is that Democrats, the Democratic Party used to be a broad inclusive group and the Republican Party used to be a broad inclusive group and they had tons of internal conflict with other members of their own political party. And increasingly the two groups have gone more and more different from each other. And so this idea of sorting or the emergence
保守派。过去，人们的社会人口统计类别并不决定他们属于哪个党派。但如今，如果你告诉我某人是白人福音派，你就能很清楚地知道那个人属于哪个党派。种族、性别以及所有其他类似的问题或其他人口和社会类别也是如此。所以问题的一部分在于，民主党过去是一个广泛的包容性群体，共和党过去也是一个广泛的包容性群体，他们与自己政党的其他成员之间存在大量的内部冲突。而这两个群体正变得越来越不同。因此，这种“分类”或“政党作为超级身份”的出现，是我们近几十年来变得如此宗派化的主要原因之一。
of party as a mega identity is one of the major reasons why we've become so much more sectarian in recent decades. So I was reading the paper, I was thinking about how to date this or what might be some of the underlying causes of how we've gotten to this point. And I started thinking about the end of the fairness doctrine in 1987, which for listeners we may not remember this, it was a regulation that required the TV networks offered equal time to opposing views. Was that a factor? Or would you look at, say, the rise of Newt Gingrich in Congress or the election of Ronald Reagan? Or do we go all the way back to the 60s? Well, to some degree, we're still fighting the battles of the 60s, but you can't really
我在读这篇论文时，一直在思考如何确定它的时间，或者我们走到这一步的潜在原因可能是什么。我开始想到1987年《公平原则》（Fairness Doctrine）的终结，对于听众来说，我们可能不记得了，这是一项要求电视网络为对立观点提供平等时间的法规。这是一个因素吗？还是你会关注国会中纽特·金里奇（Newt Gingrich）的崛起或罗纳德·里根（Ronald Reagan）的当选？还是我们要追溯到60年代？嗯，在某种程度上，我们仍在进行60年代的斗争，但你不能真正地
date this surging sectarianism to the 60s, in large part because it was really after the 60s that you saw the party realignment, right? So it used to be that relatively conservative Southerners were in the Democratic Party. And it really wasn't until after the 60s that you saw this wholesale shift of conservative Democrats of conservative Southerners to the Republican Party. But yes, you're exactly right about things like the Fairness Doctrine and Newt Gingrich. So the Fairness Doctrine was a post-World War II law that required that anybody using the broadcast error had to discuss politically sensitive topics, or at least when they discussed those topics, they had to do it in a way that
将这种激增的宗派主义追溯到60年代，很大程度上是因为在60年代之后，你才真正看到了政党重组，对吧？过去，相对保守的南方人属于民主党。直到60年代之后，你才真正看到保守派民主党人、保守派南方人向共和党的全面转移。但是的，关于《公平原则》和纽特·金里奇之类的事情，你说得完全正确。《公平原则》是二战后的一项法律，要求任何使用广播频道的人在讨论政治敏感话题时，或者至少在讨论这些话题时，必须以一种
was fair to, you know, Democrats and Republicans alike. And in the United States. And in In 1987, really with support of the Reagan administration, they basically killed the fairness doctrine. And in 1988, Rush Limbaugh went into syndication. And it's not a surprise that that was the moment when the sorts of media that Rush Limbaugh really ushered in went national, went viral, if you will. And soon after that, it was 1996 that Fox News launched. MSNBC was casting around for a long time, try to find a format that worked in 2006. They figured out that basically being the liberal version of Fox News, if you will, the liberal counterpoint to Fox News was the way to do it. And there's no law in the books.
对民主党人和共和党人都公平的方式进行。而在美国，1987年，在里根政府的支持下，他们基本上废除了《公平原则》。1988年，拉什·林博（Rush Limbaugh）开始进行联合广播。毫不奇怪，那一刻正是拉什·林博真正引入的那种媒体走向全国、走向病毒式传播（如果可以这么说的话）的时刻。此后不久，1996年福克斯新闻（Fox News）开播。MSNBC长期以来一直在摸索，试图找到一种有效的模式，在2006年，他们发现基本上成为福克斯新闻的自由派版本，也就是福克斯新闻的自由派对立面，是可行之道。而且书面上没有法律，
There's no real norm anymore, at least not like there used to be, in order to have fair coverage. So, yeah, in terms of the media, there's a huge profit motive to tell people exactly what they want to hear. Anger and righteous indignation and moral fury, those things sell. And it's not just that we've seen the media changes. The politicians themselves have realized the power of this. And in that sense, there's nobody who's done a better job or a more corrosive job than Newt Gingrich. But we're not blaming the media per se. I mean, they were tapping into something that was nascent.
不再有真正的规范了，至少不像过去那样，以确保公平的报道。所以，是的，就媒体而言，告诉人们他们想听的内容有巨大的利润动机。愤怒、义愤填膺和道德狂怒，这些东西卖得好。而且不仅仅是我们看到了媒体的变化。政客们自己也意识到了这种力量。从这个意义上说，没有人比纽特·金里奇做得更好，或者说做得更具腐蚀性。但我们并不是在指责媒体本身。我的意思是，他们是在利用某种萌芽状态的东西。
Is that what you're saying? I mean, I hate to blame the media. Everyone blames the media. Well, no, there's no way the media could be at fault. Look, these things are these things are. are cyclical and recursive and multiply determined, but yes, I'm also blaming the media. Really, at the end of the day, I blame us. I blame the citizenry. I blame the body politic. I mean, it's sort of up to us how much we want to double down on our rageful fury and listen to
你是这个意思吗？我的意思是，我不想指责媒体。每个人都指责媒体。嗯，不，媒体不可能没有过错。看，这些事情是循环的、递归的，并且是由多种因素决定的，但是的，我也在指责媒体。说到底，我指责的是我们。我指责的是公民。我指责的是政治主体。我的意思是，我们想要在多大程度上加倍投入我们的愤怒狂暴，并倾听
one side of the political discourse instead of the other side. But do I think that the media play a crucial role in this? I absolutely do. Let's take the example of, of wearing masks for COVID. I mean, Fox News deserves a whole lot of blame for this. Obviously, Donald Trump does too, but it wasn't the case in other countries that half of the electorate viewed this piece of cloth over your face as tyranny, as some sort of major violation of your freedom and independence. And that was a story that was heavily built by the right-wing media ecosystem in conjunction
政治话语的一方而不是另一方，这在某种程度上取决于我们。但我认为媒体在其中扮演了关键角色吗？我绝对认为。让我们以佩戴新冠口罩为例。福克斯新闻在这方面应该受到很多指责。显然，唐纳德·特朗普（Donald Trump）也一样，但在其他国家，并没有出现一半选民将脸上这块布视为暴政，视为对你的自由和独立的一种重大侵犯的情况。这是一个由右翼媒体生态系统与
with the right wing, you know, political class, especially Donald Trump himself. And I think there's a certain irony around that because, in a sense, the COVID-19 pandemic should be a uniting force, right? I mean, we're using the slogan, we're all in this together, and yet we're not. This is something that keeps me up at night. You know, we've had this sectarianism for a while. It's as bad as it's ever been, but it's been getting worse for a long time. And And I think sometimes, like, what would it take for us to get a little better about this? And I don't mean now, I just want to be clear about this, what would it take for us to be centrists or compromise on policy? I'm not talking about that.
右翼政治阶层（尤其是唐纳德·特朗普本人）共同构建的故事。我认为这其中有一种讽刺意味，因为从某种意义上说，新冠疫情本应是一种团结的力量，对吧？我的意思是，我们一直在使用“我们同舟共济”的口号，但事实并非如此。这是让我彻夜难眠的事情。你知道，这种宗派主义我们已经存在一段时间了。它和以往一样糟糕，但它已经恶化了很长一段时间。而且我认为有时，比如，我们需要什么才能在这方面做得好一点？我不是指现在，我只是想把这一点说清楚，我们需要什么才能成为中间派或在政策上妥协？我不是在谈论那个。
I'm talking about be less rageful and hateful toward each other and be able at least to hear each other, regardless of whether we actually agree. So what would it take to get us to a place like that? And social psychologists have talked for many, many decades about the possibility that a big external threat could do. the job. And I've become alarmed about what I think is our nation's inability to do that. And COVID is one, but there was one that came earlier, which is 9-11. 9-11 brought us together for something on the order of 48 seconds. And, you know, everybody loved George Bush for those 48 seconds. And then how long was it before we hated each other even more? Now, you're going to say, well, that's because of the Iraq war and so forth. But it's in large part because of how divided we are. So now let's enter,
我谈论的是彼此之间少一点愤怒和仇恨，至少能够倾听对方，不管我们是否真的同意。那么，我们需要什么才能达到那种地步？社会心理学家几十年来一直在谈论一种巨大的外部威胁可能完成这项工作的可能性。我已经开始对我们国家无法做到这一点感到担忧。新冠疫情是一个，但之前还有一个，那就是9·11事件。9·11事件让我们团结了大约48秒。而且，你知道，在那48秒里，每个人都爱乔治·布什（George Bush）。然后过了多久，我们就更加憎恨彼此了？现在，你会说，那是因为伊拉克战争等等。但这在很大程度上是因为我们分裂得太严重了。所以现在让我们进入，
COVID-19. And the Pew Research Center conducted a major survey, representative samples from 14 different nations, asking them that agree to which, on a scale from, I think, zero to 100, the coronavirus brought the society closer together versus pushed them further apart. And relative to the other 13 nations, America is a huge outlier in terms of Americans' belief across the political divide that we are much more divided than we were before. So it wasn't inevitable. The other countries didn't have this problem. We are almost two standard deviations above the mean on that. It drove us apart measure than the second highest country, which is Spain. And about three standard deviations above the mean relative, I'm sorry, yeah, about three standard
新冠疫情。皮尤研究中心（Pew Research Center）进行了一项重大调查，对来自14个不同国家的代表性样本进行了调查，询问他们认为新冠病毒在多大程度上（在0到100的范围内）让社会更加团结，而不是更加分裂。相对于其他13个国家，美国在跨越政治鸿沟的美国人认为我们比以前更加分裂这一点上是一个巨大的异常值。所以这不是不可避免的。其他国家没有这个问题。我们在那个指标上几乎比平均水平高出两个标准差。它让我们分裂的程度比第二高的国家西班牙还要严重，并且比其他13个国家的总体平均水平高出大约三个标准差。
deviations higher than the overall mean across the 13 other nations. So yes, in principle, external threat can bring us apart. In practice, maybe the Chinese army has to make it all the way to Omaha and then we'll finally pull together because the threats that we've seen, 9-11 and COVID, they don't seem to be anywhere close to big enough. Are Democrats and Republicans equally polarized? Your paper gauges how different groups regard each other on a feeling thermometer. So are there temperature differences between Democrats and Republicans? Generally no. So the feeling thermometer, as some of your listeners may know, is a scale from zero to one. 100 where zero is cold and 100 is warm and you can evaluate, you know, if you're a Democrat,
所以我很抱歉，是的，大约比其他13个国家的总体平均水平高出三个标准差。所以是的，原则上，外部威胁可以让我们团结起来。在实践中，也许中国军队必须一直打到奥马哈，然后我们最终才会团结起来，因为我们看到的威胁，9·11和新冠疫情，似乎远不足以让我们团结。民主党人和共和党人的两极分化程度一样吗？你们的论文衡量了不同群体在“感觉温度计”上如何看待彼此。那么民主党人和共和党人之间有温度差异吗？通常没有。所以感觉温度计，正如你们的一些听众可能知道的那样，是一个从0到100的量表，其中0代表冷，100代表暖，你可以评估，你知道，如果你是民主党人，
how do you feel about your fellow Democrats and how do you feel about Republicans? And one of the things that we highlight in the paper is that feelings toward your fellow Democrats or fellow Republicans, your in-group, basically haven't changed over the last several decades. They're in the 70 to 75 range, you know, warm, pretty warm, not extremely warm. What's really changed and is driving what we think of as polarization or sectarianism is the dislike for the out-group. So if you go back to the 70s, you're feeling toward the opposing party with something like a 50 on a scale from 0 to 100. And now it's going down to about 20, which is something between we went from tepid to basically frosty on this temperature gauge.
你对你的民主党同僚感觉如何，你对共和党人感觉如何？我们在论文中强调的一点是，对你的民主党同僚或共和党同僚（你的内群体）的感觉，在过去几十年里基本上没有改变。它们在70到75的范围内，你知道，温暖，相当温暖，不是特别温暖。真正改变并推动我们所认为的两极分化或宗派主义的是对外群体的厌恶。所以如果你回到70年代，你对反对党的感觉在0到100的量表上大约是50。而现在它下降到了大约20，这在这个温度计上介于“微温”到“冰冷”之间。
In terms of whether one side has stronger dislike than the other does, pretty much no. They basically, if you plot these temporal trends over time and even if you just look at the scores these days, it's pretty similar in terms of how much they like their end group, much they dislike their, dislike the other group. I will say, and this is, I think, an important distinction, is that we're talking about the general public, the mass public here, so Americans, you know, residents and citizens. But the political elites, especially political politicians, they really have polarized when it comes to ideas. And for that classification, like when we're thinking of politicians in particular, the Republicans have gone further to the right than the Democrats have gone to the left. Why is this type of sectarianism so dangerous? How is it a threat to democracy?
就一方是否比另一方有更强烈的厌恶感而言，几乎没有。他们基本上，如果你绘制这些随时间变化的趋势，即使你只看这些天的分数，他们在喜欢内群体和不喜欢外群体方面的程度也非常相似。我会说，我认为这是一个重要的区别，我们在这里讨论的是普通大众，也就是美国人，你知道，居民和公民。但政治精英，尤其是政客，他们在思想上确实已经两极分化了。对于这种分类，比如当我们特别想到政客时，共和党人向右走的程度比民主党人向左走的程度要远。为什么这种宗派主义如此危险？它如何威胁到民主？
Well, let me ask you, if you believe that the people on the other side are not just, they don't just have the wrong political ideas, but they're dangerous for America and Americans. Or if you believe that, again, it's not really that we just disagree, it's that the other side is, quote, downright evil. And these are the exact, measures that political scientists are using to assess this stuff. And even on the downright evil question, 42% of Democrats and 42% Republicans believe that the members of the other party are literally downright evil. Would you be willing to sacrifice a little bit of democracy to make sure that you keep the other side out of office? Would you be willing to vote for somebody that that clearly
嗯，让我问你，如果你认为另一方的人不仅仅是，不仅仅是有错误的政治思想，而且他们对美国和美国人来说是危险的。或者如果你认为，再说一次，这不仅仅是我们意见不合，而是另一方是，引用，“彻头彻尾的邪恶”。这些正是政治学家用来评估这些东西的精确指标。即使在“彻头彻尾的邪恶”这个问题上，42%的民主党人和42%的共和党人认为对方政党的成员确实是彻头彻尾的邪恶。你是否愿意牺牲一点民主来确保你把另一方挡在办公室之外？你是否愿意投票给一个明显
was not behaving in ways that you thought were acceptable? Clearly tried to suppress the vote, maybe of some black people, maybe of, of, you know, some of the other people that happen to be in your unpreferred social demographics, the answer is more and more of us are willing to do those things. Would you even support potential violence in support of your political goals? Well, I don't really understand why you wouldn't, right? This is, this is in a sense a moral tradeoff. And each individual case that you get, like would I support a little bit of violence to make sure that Donald Trump can't, you know, keep kids in cages or if you're Republican to make sure that Democrats can't keep murdering unborn children, you know, you see why people would say, look, a little bit of
行为方式你认为不可接受的人？明显试图压制投票，也许是一些黑人的投票，也许是，你知道，一些恰好属于你非首选社会人口统计学的其他人，答案是越来越多的人愿意做这些事情。你甚至会支持为了你的政治目标而采取潜在的暴力吗？嗯，我真的不明白为什么你不会，对吧？这在某种意义上是一种道德权衡。你得到的每一个个案，比如我是否会支持一点暴力来确保唐纳德·特朗普不能，你知道，把孩子关在笼子里，或者如果你是共和党人，为了确保民主党人不能继续谋杀未出生的孩子，你知道，你明白为什么人们会说，看，一点点
violence to prevent that or a little bit of sacrificing of democratic principle. Those are tradeoffs I'm willing to take. The problem, as I'm sure you can figure out, is, okay, so that's one case or two case, but over hundreds, thousands, tens of thousands of people making those decisions, you end up having really damaged democracy. And I guess I would love to have your listeners ask themselves in a world where you've really damaged democracy because you've fought so hard for the political ends rather than the, you know, democratic means, you've ended up with a world where it's really about power. It's really about power and domination. And whom has that ever served other than the people who have power to impose that power over the people who don't have
暴力来防止这种情况，或者一点点牺牲民主原则。这些是我愿意接受的权衡。问题在于，我相信你能想出来，好吧，那是一个案例或两个案例，但成百上千、成千上万的人做出这些决定，你最终会严重损害民主。我想我很乐意让你的听众问问自己，在一个因为你为政治目的而不是为民主手段而奋斗得如此努力，从而严重损害了民主的世界里，你最终得到的世界是一个真正关于权力和统治的世界。除了那些有权将这种权力强加给没有权力的人的人之外，这还服务过谁？
power? That sounds pretty dire. A couple months ago, we had another psychologist on the podcast, Tanya Israel, who was talking about a book that she recently published that talks about how to have productive conversations with people you disagree with politically. Do you think that encouraging these kinds of personal conversations and connections can make a difference on a larger scale? Well, it's that last part, you know, where the rubber meets the road. So if what you're asking me is, do I think that having meaningful conversations with people on the other side can reduce the sectarianism? Yeah, I definitely do. Get people face to face, ideally push them to try to understand each other, even if they don't agree, don't necessarily, don't push them
这听起来很可怕。几个月前，我们在播客上邀请了另一位心理学家坦尼娅·以色列（Tanya Israel），她谈到了一本她最近出版的书，书中谈到了如何与你在政治上意见不合的人进行富有成效的对话。你认为鼓励这种个人对话和联系能在更大范围内产生影响吗？嗯，这就是最后一部分，你知道，也就是关键所在。所以如果你问我的是，我是否认为与另一方的人进行有意义的对话可以减少宗派主义？是的，我绝对认为。让人们面对面，理想情况下推动他们尝试理解彼此，即使他们不同意，不一定，不要推动他们
towards centristism, just toward comprehensibility without demonization. I think that can work. But you're talking about at scale. That is, there's hundreds of millions of American voters, or a voting age anyway. Do I think there's something that we can implement that is scalable to get people outside of their sectarian mindsets, their vilification of the opposing party. I haven't seen it yet. I'm not giving up, but I think we are on a bad road. And unless we are willing to challenge not only the evildoers on the other side, but also the very, very righteous people on our side to make sure that they're not overstating the case and so forth. I don't see how we can bridge this on a mass scale. At least I don't see how we can do that yet. What about social media as an
走向中间主义，只是走向在不妖魔化的情况下实现可理解性。我认为这可以奏效。但你谈论的是规模化。也就是说，有数亿美国选民，或者至少是投票年龄的人。我是否认为有什么我们可以实施的、可扩展的东西来让人们摆脱他们的宗派心态，摆脱他们对反对党的诋毁。我还没有看到。我没有放弃，但我认为我们走在一条糟糕的道路上。除非我们愿意挑战不仅是另一方的恶人，而且还有我们这一方非常、非常正义的人，以确保他们没有夸大其词等等。我不明白我们如何能在更大范围内弥合这一点。至少我还没有看到我们如何能做到这一点。那么社交媒体作为一种
opportunity? I mean, that is on a mass scale already. And I know a lot of people on the right are fleeing some of the standard social media channels now to go over to places like parlor. But what if there were something sort of, you know, the holy good social media channel with some other name that we haven't invented yet. Again, I think that the cavalry is not coming. I think that the solutions are going to rest with us. And the reason why is there's nothing about Twitter or Facebook that drives us apart. It's about human psychology in conjunction with, again, the profit motive, right? So Facebook and Twitter make money when people engage with content more. But isn't that kind of misdirecting some of the blame? I mean, why is it that Facebook and Twitter tend to stoke up our rage so much? Well, because they know
机会呢？我的意思是，那已经在很大程度上实现了。我知道现在右派的很多人正在逃离一些标准的社交媒体渠道，转而前往像Parler这样的地方。但如果有一种，你知道，某种“神圣的”社交媒体渠道，用我们还没发明出来的其他名字呢？再说一次，我认为“骑兵”不会来。我认为解决方案将取决于我们。原因在于，Twitter或Facebook本身并没有什么东西让我们分裂。这是关于人类心理学与，再说一次，利润动机的结合，对吧？所以Facebook和Twitter在人们更多地参与内容时赚钱。但这难道不是在转移部分指责吗？我的意思是，为什么Facebook和Twitter倾向于如此煽动我们的愤怒？嗯，因为他们知道
from their algorithm that that's the sort of content that people really engage deeply with. For whatever reason, we tend to find it very, very satisfying to focus on how terrible the other side is. Billy Brady and his colleagues published a terrific paper a few years back. This is in Proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences, where they looked at the likelihood of content being retweeted, and they found that it was really moralized emotional content that significantly increased the likelihood of retweeting and particularly within rather than between echo chambers. So liberals are tweeting to liberals and conservatives to conservatives. But what does it mean to say moralized and emotional? It's not just moralized language like responsibility and duty. And it's not just emotional language like, you know,
从他们的算法中，他们知道那是人们真正深入参与的内容。无论出于什么原因，我们往往发现专注于另一方有多糟糕是非常、非常令人满意的。比利·布雷迪（Billy Brady）和他的同事几年前发表了一篇出色的论文。这是在《美国国家科学院院刊》上，他们研究了内容被转发的可能性，他们发现，确实是道德化的情感内容显著增加了转发的可能性，特别是在回声室内部而不是回声室之间。所以自由派在向自由派转发，保守派在向保守派转发。但说“道德化”和“情感化”是什么意思？这不仅仅是像“责任”和“义务”这样的道德化语言。这也不仅仅是像，你知道，
sad. It's moralized emotional language like evil, like shame. These are the things. things that we love to retweet. So you ask me, do I think that we could build a social media ecosystem that plays to the better angels of our nature? I think in principle we can, but probably only among the people who are especially oriented toward trying to be less demonizing of the other side, which unfortunately is not most of us. It reminds me of the early days of the internet when it was so altruistic and it was supposed to be to bring people together and we would never sell anything on the internet, you know, that it should be no advertising. And it's morphed into something that's totally unrecognizable now from what DARPA had created.
“悲伤”这样的情感语言。这是像“邪恶”、“羞耻”这样的道德化情感语言。这些是我们喜欢转发的东西。所以你问我，我是否认为我们可以建立一个迎合我们人性中善良天使的社交媒体生态系统？我认为原则上我们可以，但可能只在那些特别倾向于尝试减少对另一方妖魔化的人群中，不幸的是，我们大多数人并非如此。这让我想起了互联网的早期，当时它是如此利他，本应将人们聚集在一起，我们永远不会在互联网上卖任何东西，你知道，它应该没有广告。而它现在已经演变成了一种与达帕（DARPA）最初创造的东西完全无法辨认的样子。
Yes, I just want to underscore again, it's easy to blame the internet, and I do. I do blame Twitter. I do blame Facebook. But let's be clear that their blame isn't the source. It isn't the root of this problem. The root of this problem is something in human psychology, and it is, you know, about intergroup psychology, inter-political party psychology, where we just engage incredibly deeply with this sort of vilification content. I mean, whom would you want to retweet? Would you want to retreat the person who says,
是的，我只是想再次强调，指责互联网很容易，我也这样做。我确实指责Twitter。我确实指责Facebook。但我们要清楚，他们的指责并不是源头。它不是这个问题的根源。这个问题的根源在于人类心理学中的某种东西，它是，你知道，关于群体间心理学，政党间心理学，我们只是极其深入地参与这种诋毁内容。我的意思是，你会想转发谁？你会想转发那个说，
you know, I'm pro-choice. I think that should be the right of every woman. But look, it's a complex issue and I'd love to hear everyone's thoughts. Or the person who says, I'm pro-choice. It's the right of a woman. Say what you want. I won't change my mind. And I think, look, the data suggests that it's the latter one. And that that one. That one. wasn't even an enraged, vilifying tweet. It was just a morally certain definitive sort of tweet. And, you know, social media love that. Why do social media love that? Because humans love that. That's what appeals to us. It pushes our deep, deep buttons, yeah. So that brings me to where you normally work, I mean, a lot of, well, normally, I mean, where you work a lot of the time, you study
“你知道，我支持选择权。我认为那应该是每个女性的权利。但看，这是一个复杂的问题，我很乐意听到大家的想法。”的人，还是那个说，“我支持选择权。这是女性的权利。随你怎么说。我不会改变主意。”的人？我认为，看，数据表明是后者。而且那个。那个。甚至不是一个愤怒的、诋毁的推文。它只是一个道德上确定、定义明确的推文。而且，你知道，社交媒体喜欢那样。为什么社交媒体喜欢那样？因为人类喜欢那样。这就是吸引我们的东西。它触动了我们内心深处、深处的按钮，是的。所以这把我带到了你通常工作的地方，我的意思是，很多，嗯，通常，我的意思是，你工作的大部分时间，你研究
a romantic relationship's marriage is an area of expertise for you. And I'm wondering how you got from studying marriage to being involved in this particular paper. Well, yeah. I mean, I have a very, very clear origin story for this. People used to ask me, you know, how did you get interested in studying, you know, romantic attraction or marriage? And I was like, well, isn't everybody interested in that? And, you know, it was nebulous.
浪漫关系，婚姻是你的专业领域。我想知道你是怎么从研究婚姻转到参与这篇特定论文的。嗯，是的。我的意思是，我有一个非常、非常清晰的起源故事。人们过去常问我，你知道，你是怎么对研究，你知道，浪漫吸引力或婚姻感兴趣的？我说，嗯，难道每个人都对那个感兴趣吗？而且，你知道，它是模糊的。
But this one, I can tell you exactly what happened. It was two years ago, and I was watching the Christine Blasey Ford, Brett Kavanaugh hearings in the Senate. And she spoke in the morning and had what I perceived to be extremely compelling, devastating testimony. He came out in the afternoon and fulminated, and I, you know, basically blew our hair back, you know, while watching through the television screen. And it was just clear, even by the end of that day, when, you know, I was paying attention on Twitter, I was paying attention on the various cable news networks, it was just clear that if you thought he was a rapist frat boy in advance, you thought he was a rapist
但这一次，我可以告诉你到底发生了什么。那是两年前，我正在观看参议院的克里斯汀·布莱西·福特（Christine Blasey Ford）和布雷特·卡瓦诺（Brett Kavanaugh）的听证会。她在上午发言，并发表了在我看来极其令人信服、毁灭性的证词。他在下午出来并大声疾呼，我，你知道，基本上在透过电视屏幕观看时，把我们的头发都吹向后方。而且很清楚，甚至在那天结束时，当，你知道，我在关注Twitter，我在关注各种有线新闻网络时，很清楚，如果你事先认为他是一个强奸犯兄弟会男孩，你事后也认为他是一个强奸犯
frat boy after. And if you thought he was, if you thought this was a vast, diabolical democratic conspiracy to destroy this man's reputation, then, you know, you thought that before, you now think that after as well. And I just became concerned. Like, what is the future of a country like this that can go through this much additional content, this much additional information, and change so far as I can tell, nobody's mind in the entire country? Maybe there's like, I don't know, Ethel from some, you know, Fresno maybe changed her mind. But basically nobody's mind changes. And then I really worried, like, what is the future, like, what's the future? Like, what's the end game here? There's nobody who can speak across the divide. There's no Walter Cronkite.
兄弟会男孩。如果你认为，如果你认为这是一场巨大的、邪恶的民主党阴谋，旨在摧毁这个人的名誉，那么，你知道，你之前那样认为，你现在也那样认为。我只是开始担心。像这样的国家，在经历了这么多额外的内容、这么多额外的信息之后，据我所知，没有改变全国任何人的想法，它的未来是什么？也许有，我不知道，弗雷斯诺的埃塞尔（Ethel）可能改变了主意。但基本上没有人改变主意。然后我真的很担心，像，未来是什么？像，结局是什么？没有人能跨越鸿沟说话。没有沃尔特·克朗凯特（Walter Cronkite）。
How do we start hating each other less? And I couldn't figure it out. And I thought, I mean, this insight basically commandeered my intellectual life. I was struggling to think about anything else. And I thought, it's a bummer that I don't have any knowledge about that. And then I realized, wait a minute, maybe the 20 plus years of my life that I've devoted to understanding what makes for an effective or a successful versus an unsuccessful marriage or family life. And I realized that if we were to take the major insights from, I don't know, 75 years of relationship science and say, well, what is it that creates a good marriage and flipped the question to the rather diabolical one of what would the most toxic possible marriage look like? And it's easy to say it, right? You would be as contemptuous
我们如何开始减少对彼此的仇恨？我无法弄清楚。我想，我的意思是，这个洞察力基本上征服了我的智力生活。我很难去想别的事情。我想，遗憾的是我对此一无所知。然后我意识到，等一下，也许我投入了20多年生命去理解什么造就了有效或成功的婚姻或家庭生活。我意识到，如果我们从，我不知道，75年的关系科学中汲取主要见解，并说，嗯，是什么创造了美好的婚姻，然后把问题翻转为关于什么是最糟糕的、最毒的婚姻可能是什么样子的邪恶问题？这很容易说，对吧？你会尽可能地
of each other as possible. And any time you had an opportunity, to interpret what your partner did, you'd make sure that you interpreted his behavior in the nastiest way that you could. And you would surround yourself by people that think he is beneath contempt and can't figure out why you were ever with him. And so we can go through and sort of distill or extract from the relationships field real lessons about what good relationships look like and what bad relationships look like. And if we take those characteristics of the worst possible marriage we a design and we superimpose them on our body politic, we've built it. We have built the most toxic marriage I can't imagine. And also, last thing on this, the relationship space has some knowledge of
蔑视对方。而且每当你有一个机会，去解读你的伴侣做了什么，你都会确保你以你能做出的最恶毒的方式解读他的行为。而且你会让自己被那些认为他卑劣到极点、无法理解你为什么曾经和他在一起的人所包围。所以我们可以通过并从关系领域中提炼或提取关于美好关系是什么样子以及糟糕关系是什么样子的真实教训。如果我们采取那些最糟糕的婚姻的设计特征，并将它们叠加在我们的政治主体上，我们就构建了它。我们构建了我想象不到的最毒的婚姻。而且，关于这个的最后一件事，关系领域有一些知识
how to improve toxic marriages, right? There is something called marital therapy. A lot of people go when they absolutely hate each other, and some percentage of those actually get better. And so that is what really pivoted me into this space in general. So maybe we can close on a more positive note and talk about possible solutions. I know that your paper had a few ideas. Can you talk about what we might be able to do to dial back this animosity? Well, some structural fixes could help almost certainly. So, you know, we've got these very, very gerrymandered house of representative districts where, you know, the idea that you would lose an election to the person on the other side is impossible. So the only threat really is that you would be,
关于如何改善有毒的婚姻，对吧？有一种东西叫婚姻治疗。很多人在他们绝对憎恨对方时去，其中一些人实际上好转了。所以这就是真正让我转向这个领域的原因。所以也许我们可以以一个更积极的基调结束，谈谈可能的解决方案。我知道你的论文有一些想法。你能谈谈我们可能做些什么来减少这种敌意吗？嗯，一些结构性的修复几乎肯定会有帮助。所以，你知道，我们有这些非常、非常被操纵的众议院选区，你知道，你会在选举中输给另一方的人的想法是不可能的。所以唯一的威胁实际上是，你会被
you would be beaten in the primary by somebody even more extreme than you are. We could fix those sorts of things. I know that a lot of people, especially on the left right now, are very disturbed by the electoral college and generally the small state bias where, you know, a vote in Wyoming is worth 60 times as much for the Senate as a vote in California and those sorts of issues. My concern is that the polarization, the sectarianism itself, is going to make solutions to those problems impossible because those problems, solutions. of those problems will benefit one party or the other, and we aren't in a moment when our leaders
在初选中被一个比你更极端的人击败。我们可以修复那些东西。我知道很多人，特别是在左派，现在对选举人团和总体上的小州偏见感到非常不安，你知道，怀俄明州的一张选票在参议院的价值是加利福尼亚州选票的60倍，以及诸如此类的问题。我的担忧是，两极分化，宗派主义本身，将使这些问题的解决方案变得不可能，因为这些问题，解决方案。这些问题的解决方案将使一方或另一方受益，而我们现在不是一个我们的领导人
are willing to take one for the team for the betterment of democracy. So I keep coming back to this thing that I think is not a satisfying solution, but it is one that we talk about in our paper as well, is trying to inculcate a deeper sense of humility, a deeper sense of recognizing that we all have our life experiences. And those life experiences tilt us to have certain sorts of moral understandings of how things function. And yet, they're not universally true. And other people have different life experiences. And once we have a deep understanding of those things, I believe we can become more tolerant. What mechanism is going to get us to the place where we deeply understand people on the other side and therefore continue to disagree with them, of course, but vilify them less?
愿意为了民主的改善而“为团队牺牲”的时刻。所以我一直回到这个我认为不是一个令人满意的解决方案的事情，但它也是我们在论文中讨论的，是试图灌输一种更深层次的谦逊感，一种更深层次的认识，即我们都有我们的人生经历。而那些人生经历使我们倾向于对事物如何运作有某种道德理解。然而，它们并非普遍正确。其他人有不同的人生经历。一旦我们对这些事情有了深刻的理解，我相信我们可以变得更加宽容。什么机制能让我们达到深刻理解另一方的人，从而继续与他们意见不合，当然，但减少对他们的诋毁？
I'm not exactly sure. Well, thank you for joining me today, Dr. Finkel. It's been really interesting. Thank you. Yeah, I'm glad I could end on a positive note. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeatingof Psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondy. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mill. skills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不太确定。嗯，谢谢你今天加入我，芬克尔博士。这真的很有趣。谢谢。是的，我很高兴我能以一个积极的基调结束。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你有评论或对未来播客的想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪（Chris Kondy）。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。